let's see who else wants to chat why
don't we go to the 404 area code caller
from 404 what's going on with you today
hi David this is Jeff from Atlanta how
you doing good go ahead I was calling
the few to see if you could clarify what
you mean about those on the Left who
aren't convinced with the truck Russia
story let me see if I can clarify what
you want me to clarify what do you you
want me to clarify what I mean by you
said there's a microcosm on the left
because Udo you've said this before but
maybe I'm just quoting you Oh like that
there's a contingent of the left that
doesn't think there's any Trump Russia
story yeah right and why why you feel
that way why do I feel that there is a
contingent or why do I feel that they
believe that and I'm just I'm not
understanding why do you feel they
believe that oh what depends I mean some
a lot as I've talked about before some
people on the Left see the Trump Russia
story as inextricably inextricably tied
to the strength of the Hillary and
Bernie candidacy so there are people on
the Left who feel as though if they
acknowledge that there's clearly
something going on with Trump and Russia
that it sort of excuses Hillary
Clinton's loss or makes it seem as
though Bernie is not as strong of a
candidate I just reject I reject that
right but I think that there are people
on the Left who believe that and thus
feel compelled to say there's no Trump
Russia story okay well I can understand
that but if someone who does not really
really go along with the Trump Russia
story maybe there is there isn't my my
my opinion is that instead of talking
about the media has taken Russia and and
talked about it at nauseam instead of
talking about medicare-for-all raising
the minimum wage
climate change real issues now sir this
is a very important issue with the
different brushes story but I feel that
that they're using it
we present to keep from talking about
the progressive agenda that people on
the Left want to push yeah
well listen Jeff here's the heading hold
on was corporate media by and large
talking about those issues before the
Trump Russia story because I've been
saying on the program for ten years that
corporate media doesn't talk about that
stuff so I agree with you
corporate media generally doesn't talk
about those important issues we talk
about them here but that's been going on
for as long as I've been doing the show
I don't think it has anything to do with
Trump Russia unless you can sort of
prove me well if you think about it the
Trump Russia story in in a way has led
to the ad pocalypse on YouTube because
there are people like you out there
people like secular talk people like the
humanist report and Jimmy Dore out there
trying to set people straight and ad
pocalypse comes along with affect
everyone who's trying to whether you're
on the left or the right if you're not
parroting the the corporate media
narrative they will be monetize you and
you hold on a second what evidence do
you have that it's one's position one's
position on issues that will get you D
monetized because I've not experienced
that and I you also said that that the
Trump Russia story led to YouTube ad
pocalypse I've not heard that before
what evidence do you have to support
that well let's see here I've seen
multiple videos from like Jimmy Dore and
calculon's the instructor talk talking
about their D monetization of how their
videos are being be monetized right okay
and then I hear like people like Steven
Crowder who I really don't like but I
listened to to get the other side he's
also being demonetized so it seems like
anyone who's putting out politics on
YouTube YouTube has demonetized in it
okay so what does that have to do with
Russia
you said Trump Russia caused ad
pocalypse how absolutely because there
is this because of the Russian troll
farms and people posting posting on
Facebook and and other social media
sites it's kind of led to a crackdown of
independent media because
you could be a Russian troll and so
we're going to have to yeah but Jeff I
hate to interrupt you but there's no
evidence of that whatsoever I mean I I
don't know anyone who's been more
wrapped up in ad pocalypse that I have
and there's absolutely unless you can
cite evidence other than you've just
heard about some videos being D
monetized contemporaneously with when
Russian trolls have been an issue I
don't know if anything that connects
those issues well I just see maybe like
a strange coincidence then because after
the Hilary lost the election you know
first few months of 2017 those out there
promoting a certain point of view or or
an agenda yeah or being demonetised
yeah but Jeff hold on a second so you
know what around the time that D
monetization hit that ad pocalypse hit
Donald Trump announced he wanted
transgender people out of the military
coincidence right at the exact same time
Trump wants trans people out of the
military I get demonetised
are they connected well no but right I
can see where I put that if you look at
it from a larger perspective is try and
suppress independent media and then
using the Russian troll farm as an
excuse to but it's not used as an
expense or not been used as an excuse
Jeff I got a run but there's just no
evidence for what you're saying I'm
right in there in criticizing what's
taken place with the monetization but I
don't know of anything that connects it
to the things you're pointing out